cuál de los siguientes pares ordenados
es solución para la siguiente ecuación
4x menos 1 igual a 3 yemas 5 bueno
tenemos estas opciones para saber si un
par ordenada es una solución necesitamos
recordar que la convención en los pares
ordenados es que la primera coordenada
es la coordenada x y la segunda es la
coordenada y si éste para ordenada fuera
una solución significa que si x es 3 y 6
entonces se cumpliría la igualdad en
esta ecuación vamos a probarlo 4x debe
ser igual a 3 4 por 3 menos uno igual a
tres porque y si este par fuera la
solución
la aie debe ser igual a 25 lo único que
hice fue sustituir tres en cada lugar
que encontré una equis y cada que me
encontré una y la sustituye con un 2
ahora veamos si esto es correcto 4 por 3
es 12 12 menos 1 es igual a 3 por 2 6
65 y esto 12 menos uno es igual a 11 y 6
más 5 es igual a 11 esto se cumple esta
opción 32 es una solución a esta
ecuación ahora veamos la segunda opción
de la misma manera que lo hicimos
anteriormente cuando encontramos una x
la sustituiremos con un 2 y cuando
encontremos una de las sustituiremos con
un 3 en esta ecuación 4 por equis pero x
es igual a dos es cuatro por dos menos
uno igual a tres porque y es igual a
tres
+ 5 veamos si esto se cumple 4 por 2 es
88 menos uno es igual a 3 por 39 más 58
menos uno es 7 y 95 es 14 esto no se
cumple 7 es diferente de 14 esto
claramente no se cumple por lo que está
por lo que esta opción de sólo 23 no es
una solución x 2 y 3 no satisfacen esta
ecuación la opción sólo 32 es la
solución